mein name ist luca wöhrle liebe freunde
ich darf euch heute recht herzlich
willkommen heißen am dienstag
selbstverständlich wieder zu einer neuen
episode
wir starten heute direkt mit einem video
von einer person die dort runter
geschrieben hat dass sie jeder mensch
dabei wohl anfangen muss zu lachen wenn
er das sieht ja war mega lustig was
herzinfarkt wegen schwindel gerade
bekommen was geht da ab ich werde
niemals verstehen wie unfreundlich man
im einzelhandel sein kann es dann sein
wird
[Musik]
gestern abend voll einschlafen habe ich
das gesehen ich hatte den größen nach
flash den ich je hatte jemals jeweils 15
sekunden zeit 15 14 13 12
12 wie können zwei menschen so unfassbar
los sein
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich schon auf mein mikro und
die sitze new york recklinghausen tik
tok habe ich auch schon gestern abend
gesehen und hatte auch den kompletten
dachfläche ich weiß nicht wie sie tickt
doch das macht er ja bei der algorithmus
auf der homepage ist so geisteskrank gut
hier
wie kommt man auf so eine scheiße neuen
leute heute probleme brachte zitronen
und der band let's go okay man ein
bisschen schütteln mit auch der
geschmack stärkere
richtig geil
ich bin zwar kein fan von eis die
zitrone aber bei kappa ist das einfach
nur marcel marschall einfach ist er ist
ja eigentlich geil findet ihr das freut
mich mega dass skype in das danke dir an
der stelle auch noch mal für deinen
review wirklich mega geil ich finde es
auch richtig geiler diese geile review
von diesem geilen heiße gemacht hat
einfach geil einfach geil
ich schwöre jedes mal war das so und die
sache ist die drehen das ja ohne
publikum also wie queens musters für
diesen promi dann sei wenn er dazu steht
auch hejazi stand hier im weg und da
kommt wieder so ein fake lachen oder die
einfach da denkst stell dir vor meine
videos werden mit fake lachen
danke danke danke danke
also ich hab da ein witz vorbereitet
danke danke also der witz lautet ging
ein vogel in den wald und schreit ich
einfach mal ins falsche auto
eingestiegen
er ist das also
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich glaube ich habe noch nie was süßes
gesehen als ein frosch der sich mit
wasser wäscht du bist 14 und kollegen
du zeigst mir gar nicht wahrheit
ich schwöre das waren die schlimmsten
lehrer aber auf der anderen seite auch
die besten weil real talk dadurch ist
man halt wirklich leiser geworden weil
der lehrer einfach sagt okay das wird
glaube ich keinen lehrer jemand zu sagen
aber dann war es halt einfach so dass
damit eine stelle bekommen und ende aber
wenn du selber merkst du fehler machst
du jetzt vor allem an die tafel
[Musik]
geschrieben
dann ist das wäre nicht nötig gewesen
aber real talk ich wusste auch nie wie
ich mich in solchen situationen hätte
verhalten sollen bedankt man sich dann
erstmal für das geld was er
augenscheinlich dann das geschenk ist
oder die für die karte war ganz
schwierige situation
[Musik]
ich finde dieses
das christlich mal machen aber ich finde
es unglaublich dass sein bruder machte
er war bereits wenn zu viel wird man ja
auch immer ja ich glaube dass das video
aus hamburg ist weil realtech dass wir
hier in hamburg auch vor ein paar tagen
und ich denke einfach so okay ich hatte
disney plus auch schon vorher so aber
spätestens jetzt würde ich mir holen was
das für eine kreative werbung degas wir
haben also nicht in die aussage länder
aber ich kann auch noch unterwäsche
tragen obwohl
[Musik]
das ist genau mein dicker was ist falsch
gelaufen weil mein humor
[Musik]
also wenn ich irgend jemand fragen
sollte was mein typ mädchen ist vom
äußeren dann wohl wie heißt sie auf ins
tal
wie lange brauche ich von hamburg nach
groningen das aktuelle verkehrsaufkommen
von hamburg richtung niederlande ist
niedrig eine fahrtzeit beträgt etwa zwei
stunden und 53 minuten
[Musik]